what is going on YouTube ohhara here
welcome back to my youtube channel and
today we will be looking at dawn island
and the Goa Kingdom which is the very
first island to have ever appeared in a
one-piece story and yes it is the very
same island that Luffy started his
adventure from in this video we will be
looking at its geography its history the
people who live there and what the
future holds for the place
as always guys if you're not familiar
with the one piece manga be careful
because there will be spoilers ahead but
now without further ado let's get right
into it now before we get into the
details of the island and the Kingdom on
it I want to talk a little bit about
where in the one-piece world exactly
dawn Island is located to better
understand the role it plays in the
world and in order to do that first of
all we have to look at the one-piece
world in general and as you might know
the one-piece world is one big planet
that we haven't learned the name of yet
and this planet consists mostly of one
huge ocean which is called the blue sea
and it makes up pretty much the entire
world the only elements that disturb
this huge masses of water on the entire
planet is one big continent the so
called red line it is a huge continent
that spans around the whole world in a
circle and kind of splits the planet in
half like that the next really important
element is a so-called grand line it is
a very long chain of islands that runs
in 90-degree angle to the red line and
also spans around the world and you to
this angle the grand line and the red
line kind of split the world into four
quarters and each of these quarters are
different seas and there are four C's of
viously for four quarters the first is
the north blue in the north the south
blue in the south the west bow in the
west and the east blue in the east and
this is also where our island dawn
island is located and where most of the
first part of the one piece story takes
place before we move on to these blue I
want to quickly mention that of course
there's also the calm belt in the
one-piece world that is a zone that
spans the Grand Line that basically
makes it impossible or nearly impossible
to move in to the Grand Line
by any of the seas by any other means
than using the way over reverse mountain
it is an area without currents without
wind which is why it's called the calm
belt but also additionally you can't
just draw over the calm belt because it
is filled with Sea Kings the giant
monsters of the sea that we also got to
know in the first chapter of one piece
and last but not least there are
so-called sky oceans there is the white
sea and the white white sea that our
oceans in the sky made of cloud like
substances that also have islands and
inhabitants and people living in the sky
so that is pretty much what the
one-piece world is made out of now let's
take a closer look at the ocean where
Dawn Island is located rather the east
blue and the east blue is like I just
said one of the four Great seas that's
been the one-piece world and like the
other three seas it is basically almost
entirely made out of water and there are
some islands that are scarcely scattered
across the sea due to their geography of
the world the east blue of course also
brought us the red line which acts like
a natural border between the different
seas and in one of the movies it is also
referred to as the sea of schemes by a
group of villagers in general the east
blue is known as the weakest seas in the
rest of the world which means that even
pirates who are regarded as really
threatening or high-class or dangerous
pirates or in famous pirates in the east
blue are rather seen as weak and
insignificant in the other seas and this
belief is especially pronounced in the
Grand Line where pirates from the east
blew a rather smiled upon as weak or not
strong enough so it is the more ironic
actually when you think about it that
the east blue was the birthplace of the
late pirate king gol D Roger after all
so it's really interesting that even
though some of the strongest pirates or
the strongest pirate in the world at
that time comes from these blue and that
it still didn't manage to get rid of
this image kind of makes you wonder is
it really a fact that like pirates from
the east poo are especially weak or is
it more of a fact that the east blue
might be just a little bit more peaceful
than for example the north blue who was
known for its
great warfare that's going on to the
kingdom with for example to Germer or
law war from the north blue or also
Sanji of course and even though no
official map of the east blue with the
exact location of all the islands exists
it is still mostly assumed that dawn
islands and the goa kingdom are located
rather far away from the grand line and
that's the reason why luffy had to pass
all of those islands in the East blue
arch and in many maps you'll find the
island is located somewhere in the
northeast of the sea so this is
basically the layout of the east blue
and where Dorne Island fits into this
ocean so now that we know where Dawn
Island is located in the one-piece world
and more precisely in the east blue
let's talk about the island itself and
how its structured
so basically dawn island has not been
named in the one-piece manga until
chapter 584 which was rather late in the
story shortly after the war of the
greatest at marine fort more importantly
though it was the very first island to
have appeared in the whole series in the
very first chapter of the manga because
we know that foucha village Luffy's
birthplace and the place where he met
shanks is on the very same islands and
it has appeared in the very first
chapter of one piece if you have
followed my recent videos also there are
some really interesting connections
between Dawn Island and lope town where
Rogers journey to become the king of the
Pirates began because Lok kind of
reminds you of a prologue or an epilogue
which kind of refers to the beginning or
the end of a story same as the dawn kind
of marks the threshold from the old to
the new day so kind of both of the
cities have like a symbolism that refers
to the beginning or the end of something
and it kind of draws a nice connection
between the two characters of Luffy and
Roger and kind of shows that both their
stories started with this place and
we'll see if Luffy story also ends with
this place same as for Roger we'll see
that in the future I guess also I would
like to mention here that the name dawn
island itself might be a very good
reason that the first arc in one piece
is called roman stone as well so now
let's look a little bit into the
geography and the structure of the
island itself and the
very first thing you will notice is that
the whole island of dawn island is
basically spanned by a kingdom that is
called the goa kingdom and the whole
place mostly consists of rural foreign
land with cows and a lot of grass which
is also what we are shown in the very
first chapter of one piece when we are
introduced to luffy and foucha village
itself the capital though is a little
different it is a huge city in a shape
of a circle that is surrounded by a
really really high wall and the city
itself is surrounded by a forest and
also by chain of rather low mountains
that are covered by forests sadly we do
not know how many people live in the Goa
kingdom itself or even how many villages
there are the only real village we know
is foucha village which is located on
the other side of the mountains that
kind of guard the capital city also one
of the mountains in those mountain
chains around the capital is known to us
as Mount colugo which is where the
bandits lived that raised Luffy Sabo and
ace another place we know of is the
forest that spans between the mountains
and the walls of the capital it is
called the midway forest and it's home
to a lot of very gruesome beasts next in
front of the huge gates we have the so
called great terminal which is basically
a huge dump yard and on a small patch of
water that flows in word from the ocean
between the mountains and the forest is
called Pirates Bay and in the center of
all those mountains near the coast
surrounded by forests and surrounded by
those huge walls there's the capital
city where the royalty and the nobility
lives so now that we've learned of all
those places I want to get a little bit
more into the details of what those
places look like and what makes them
special and what characterizes them and
the first place we'll be looking at is
foucha village and we know that it's a
very peaceful village also very sleepy
it's very rural
a lot of fields with cows we see a lot
of windmills it's also called the
windmill village and it lies a little
bit on the outskirts of the main goal
kingdom bounding the plains
on the foot of the mountain ranges it is
known to be Luffy's home and birthplace
and it is also
he met with shanks for the first time
and the place where he got inspired to
be a pirate and also the place of course
where he got the scar and got into the
fight with a bandit crew the village
itself is run by a mayor
that's called whoop slab so we also know
of two distinct locations in the village
the first is the parties bar that is run
by Makino who works there as a bartender
it is the place of the first
confrontation between the shanks cards
and the bandits in the first chapter and
also where Luffy eats his devil fruit
actually Makino herself has a child
after the time skip and it makes you
kind of wonder if maybe shanks kind of
dropped by a little during the time skip
in the village itself and went a little
back on a break into these blue the
second place that we learn off in foucha
village is UO
which is kind of a fish store I would
say that is owned by a man called guru
and Luffy is going there buying fish in
also the first chapter Jorah has a wife
that is called chicken which is a very
interesting name for a wife to have and
otherwise we don't really know of any
more citizens even though we we see a
lot of them looking concerned or waving
at Luffy when he leaves to to his
journey but we would never learn any
names of the village but it seems to be
rather small only consisting out of a
few houses the last thing you should
know about future village is that it has
a sea monster
at its coast that is called the Lord of
the coast and it's basically a smaller
kind of seeking that kind of attacks
every ship that tries to land there or
come close to the coast or also leave
from the coast so it kind of protects
the village in a way white also isolates
it from the world or at least from
setting out to sea the next place we're
looking at is Mount Cordoba it is the
mountain that you can always see in the
back of foucha village and it marks one
of the mountains in the mountain range
between the capital and the village
itself it is very heavily forested
there's a lot of vegetation and trees
and the mountains are rather low it is
the home of several bandit groups most
prominently the darlin family that is
the bandit group that adopted Luffy ace
and Sabo but it was also probably the
home of the bandit higuma
and his crew who were eliminated by the
shanks pirates after he Gomez death
through the Lord of the coast the
seeking monster in the port and shanks
departure from the village itself going
back probably to the Grand Line garb
came back to the village
and took Luffy from foucha village to
mount kuba to live with the Darden
family after he already had put a stayer
whom he kind of adopted on Rogers bid so
lúthien days conducted both of the
trainings there kind of under the
supervision of of Darden the Bandit
leader the family leader but mostly
trained by garb who dropped by here and
then to to train both of them later on
Saab also moved in with the Bandit crew
after he left the capital and the three
of them would spend a lot of time in
this area adventuring and
fighting and training and basically
getting unusually strong for the Aged in
a very or at a very rapid pace moving
closer again to the capital between
Mankato bow and the capital itself lies
midway forest which is a forest the area
between the mountains and the walls of
the capital itself it is mostly known to
the people of the Goa kingdom as a very
dangerous place to be for any human and
that is because there's a lot of beasts
living there dangerous animals and
dangerous places to walk around in of
course we know that saloon days before
Sabo moved in with him and Luffy the two
of them used the place as kind of a
hideout or training ground in their
youth and they would steal values
treasures and the other loot from people
in the city or at the Grey Harbor and
they would store all that treasure in
like hidden storage system they
integrated in a big tree in the forest
the plan was basically to use the money
or the treasure to
financed their ambitions of becoming a
pirate later on and leave violin itself
Luffy though who was very attached to
ace and wanted him to recognize him
followed ace into the forest and was
able to after many hardships actually
locate and find the location where they
hid their treasure and find a son Sabo
there and after that kind of the trio of
them were roaming food mountains and the
Midway forest and training and fighting
beasts and when the blue gem pirates
said the great terminal on fire and
after they defeated their captain blue
gem ace and Adam took refuge near a
river in the forest to protect
themselves from the flames once you
reach the edge of the forest you will
see a huge junkyard that is located in
front of the gates of the Goa Kingdom
capital it is basically a huge wasteland
with thrown out and unwanted yeah things
Goods machines trash and also all the
unwanted people of the capital and the
kingdom itself it is a rather lawless
land where people live in poverty and
without any medical care so many people
are very sick and are dying and starving
and so I will actually live there for
some time in secret when he ran away
from the capital and lived there with
some of the other refugees there those
people have to make the living by
collecting and remedying through the
different things that can be found in
the trash yard and kind of look for
valuable things to to sell back to
citizens of of the city itself or other
people in the tent in the trunk yard
itself at one point the world government
actually issued a inspection to be done
in the Goa Kingdom because they saw it
as a successful example of a society
where everything unnecessary is removed
at least that's how order put it so they
basically sent down a celestial dragon
to inspect if they were actually living
as a country that is worthy of being
part of the world government and to
basically get rid of all the trash the
very easy and obvious thing to do was
destroy great terminals since it was
like
accumulation of all bad and unwanted
things in the kingdom
so the nobility of course and trying not
to get their hands dirty kind of paid
the blue gem pirates to set up
explosives and set fire to the great
terminal and destroy it and he actually
did that and a lot of a lot of people
died but luckily dragon arrived in time
to to save also a lot of people to get
on their boat of the revolutionaries and
afterwards you really don't know what
happened to the great terminal if people
came back to it and are living in it
again after the inspection or if it's
empty now but it's most likely used
again as a dump yard for the capital
city also like a small fun fact here the
great terminal itself was based on Smoky
Mountain slum that is a very famous slum
in Manila and the Philippines it was
populated by the same kind of Revengers
who lived in the dump yard and like made
a living out of the things there and I
always like how all that kind of
implements those things and gets
inspiration from real-life problems or
circumstances same as for example also
in one o country that is also based on
real events from the past or real
problems that the Japanese country had
in the past another location that is
only shortly mentioned is the so called
Pirates Bay it is kind of located
between the great terminal the mountains
and the forests and it is basically just
a patch of ocean that stretches a little
bit further inwards the country and it
is where the blue gem pirates actually
used to be stationed and have their ship
otherwise the location is not really
Ernst and more next on we have the
capital city itself which is surrounded
by those huge huge walls and has a great
entrance gate that opens up to the great
terminal and this gate kind of connects
the great terminal where all the poor
people live to the first circle in the
city which is called edge town well
basically all the normal people of the
country or of the capital if
and while they are not nobility or rich
they have a decent life they live in in
nice houses they can buy nice things but
they're not wealthy enough or rich
enough to to afford super luxurious
things so they also have a regular trade
with the people from the great terminal
and are kind of like the buffer zone
between the very poor and the very rich
next to edge town there is the town
centre which is kind of where the richer
people live it is also where you're able
to get more luxurious goods or more
expensive goods and also again works
kind of as a buffer zone between normal
people and royality next up we have high
town and this is actually where the
nobles reside so also Szabo's family for
example it is a clean area with huge and
rich houses where basically all the
great mentions of the nobility are
located and it's also of course where
most of the nobilities everyday life
takes place high town is also shielded
by the town centre an edge town web by a
small wall again and again in the center
of high town there's a plateau which
serves as a base for the royal palace
where the royalty lives so the king and
queen and the ruling family of the Goa
Kingdom so now that we've learned how
the basic geography and layout of the
Goa Kingdom is let's look a little bit
into who actually lives there so we kind
of have five groups of inhabitants that
live in the Goa Kingdom or are from the
Goa Kingdom and first of all of course
on top we have the reality the people
who actually rule over the Goa Kingdom
under the royal family we have the
nobles who are like the aristocratic
families of the country and aspired to
be basically married into the royal
family as well and the most wealthy and
luxurious living of course next on of
course we have regular citizens who live
for example in foucha village or in the
lower parts of the city capital and then
we have the two groups that are kind of
like
outcasts in a sense or you have bandits
and pirates and maybe also additionally
the people who live in the great
terminal because they're also not really
considered people in a way so let's
start with reality and at the moment as
you guys might remember since we've just
recently seen him the current king of
the Goa Kingdom is king steli basically
szabo stepbrother who succeeded the
previous king after he died for
mysterious reasons quote-unquote so I
think we all know what happened there
and he's actually married to the former
princess queen sorry nan toka net if
that's how you pronounce her nan toka
net yeah I guess I guess that's how you
would spell her steli as we know is
currently add the reverie together with
Sabo who I'm really really curious what
will happen there but we'll see in the
future I guess
next on we have the nobles that we know
of and well it's not it's not a lot of
people who we know of we know of course
of Sabo himself who is probably not
considered a noble anymore since he's a
revolutionary now in a world like world
reknowned person with a heavy bounty on
his head but of course we also have his
parents outlook the third his father and
Szabo's mother who wasn't honored with
the name and also we know of a whole day
zonin the 9th and i hope by the way just
for you guys who who's know a little
japanese it's of course idiot so we can
see what what I was trying to impose
there and his daughter a hosue taco also
nice family name again like it's always
good to be called an idiot and of course
they are not introduced in a very
positive light as well next up we have
the citizens of the kingdom and again we
basically only know the citizens of who
shall village here since we didn't meet
anyone else with a real name in the
capital and we have of course Makino as
mentioned before with her child
we have whoops lab the mayor of lucia
village we have Kyoto and his wife with
a great name of chicken
and last but not least we have GARP who
we know is from the Goa Kingdom and who
is a Vice Admiral in the Marines and
also he's the father of monkey Dee
dragon and the grandfather of Luffy and
also kind of like a yeah father figure
or taking father for Ace
now the first group of outlaws we're
looking at will be the bandits and we
basically know kind of two groups of
bandits first of all there's the key
guma bandits who are by now all perished
since the crew was kind of soloed by Ben
Backman and he Kumai himself was killed
by the sea monster when he was trying to
abduct loafie and the other group of
bandits is d'harans family of course the
Bandit family who took in and raised and
trained Luffy Sabo and ace their leader
is curly Dom who was like yeah very
masculine little fetish woman with a
long orange trebly hair who used to be
very beautiful in their youth and even
though she kind of starts of rough with
all three of them she starts to grow
fond of them very very fast and actually
cares deeply for all three of them the
way she came into care of luffy and ace
is actually really funny because she
kind of seems to be blackmailed by GARP
into taking care of the kids basically
him saying if you don't look after them
I will I will run you to prison with you
and your bandits so it's not really that
she has a choice but in a weird way they
have like a kind of friendship going on
I guess and two other named members of
the bandit family are Dora who's like a
rather small guy with a turban and Magra
who's a big guy who has like a beard and
kind of haircut that reminds you of a
chicken and also there's a small dog
living with the bandit that's called
Poochie that looks kind of like he
doesn't really care about anything in
the world I mean look at that face what
does it tell you and last but not least
we have of course the pirate cruise or
the different pirates related to the Goa
Kingdom and of course the first pirates
that will come to mind there is shanks
and his crew but since they're not
really from the Goa Kingdom but just
where there like as visitors I would
kind of like let leave them out of the
list here rather interesting though of
course monkey D dragon who's a
revolutionary not a pirate but still the
most most wanted person in the world so
I think it's worth worth mentioning that
he's from this island for sure and of
course his son monkey D Luffy who now is
considered one of the Emperor's of the
sea and is currently in one okuni also
of course we have ace who also grew up
with Luffy on the island and also became
a world renown pirate under white beard
also one of the Emperor's
but as we sadly know has perished
Maxon we have the blue gem pirates who
is the pirate crew
that was tasked by the nobility to set
the great terminal on fire and who
actually fought ace and Luffy and Sabo
later on in the story and their captain
is blue gem who was probably still alive
he was defeated by Aden and ace together
and probably started a new crew after
the great terminal burned down one of
his crew members we know by name is
Porcha me and he was actually killed by
blue gem for losing against the kids so
very sympathetic person there and the
last pirate we know about from the Goa
kingdom is McGorry who is actually a
enemy only character he's not appearing
in the manga but he's interesting or
worth mentioning for the reason that
he's actually one of the few people who
we know of that has conquerors haki and
he actually was fighting Roger in his
youth and had his crew destroyed by him
and he's living in the outskirts of the
city also helping out Luffy ace and Sabo
when they were fighting a big bear and
demonstrating his conquerors hockey
there so even though he's not cannon
he's for sure a very interesting
character in a way as well so now that
we got to know the history and also the
locations and geography of the place
let's look a little bit into what the
future could hold for Don Ireland and
the Goa Kingdom itself so first of all
even though the
Kingdom and Dawn Island is usually seen
as a very peaceful and rule and more
simple country or island by the other
islands in the east blue it has still
produced some of the most infamous
people in the world
for example Luffy or ace garb or also
dragon of course additionally even
though we got to know push a village is
a very peaceful place and there might be
a lot more villages like that in the
island too we got to see the capital and
the area surrounding it as a very crucem
place and actually later on in dressrosa
luffy and Sabo compare it to the Goa
Kingdom since both Islands kind of
function through those hardcore
divisions between rich and poor and the
suppression through the royal family as
a matter of fact in the current story
the reverie is still going on and Stelly
the current king and Tsavo stepbrother
is still as the king of the Goa King and
represented in Murray jaw and taking
part in the world conference and as a
matter of fact as we know also the
Revolutionary Army including Sabo is
there to try some kind of coup so it
will be really really interesting to see
in what direction that goes also it will
be interesting to see as mentioned
before if Luffy will at one point come
back after his journey is complete and
what kind of reunion he will have with
his home country at home town and we
hope also to learn a little bit more
about dragon and his past and maybe also
about some other people who might be as
well from the Goa Kingdom for example
luffy's mother who we don't know
anything about yet so hope guys that I
could give you a nice overview over the
Goa Kingdom and Owen Island itself and
help you understand a little bit better
where Luffy comes from and what makes
this place so special and what place it
holds in the story and what potential it
has for the future I'm really curious to
what you guys think like what are your
impressions of the country itself what
does it remind you of do you have any
connections to real places in the world
what or who would you like to get to
know better from the Goa Kingdom itself
and what are your thoughts on the future
of the country and the developments that
they're every especially for Stella and
Sabo I hope you guys enjoyed the video
if you liked it leave me
if you didn't leave me a thumbs down
share your thoughts in the comments
below and otherwise I see you next time
and until then have a great week
you